armie tell us about what made you want
to be a part of telling this story you
know I thought it was an important story
I thought that it was really timely it
seems much more timely now with
everything going on I loved the message
of the film and I think that it's
important to sort of exalt the stories
of people who have good things to say do
you have more of a sympathetic feeling
towards women and women's equality women
in the workplace you know I think I
always have and I think that's why this
movie was really kind of attracted to me
attractive to me I've been really lucky
my whole life I've been surrounded by
really strong intelligent powerful women
as role models and friends and as my
wife and and all that so if anything
this sort of highlighted even more
issues to me where I'm like oh I could
probably be better about this I could
probably be more supportive about this I
could be a better husband in this way a
better partner in this way so so getting
to do it was really kind of like
refining strokes on an edge that I would
like to think I already had interesting
do you feel like playing Marty has made
you a better husband as Marty I don't
think anyone's as good of a husband as
Marty I mean he really set the bar high
but he'd also gave us something to
aspire to you know I mean he was an
incredibly progressive partner he was a
supportive husband in every single way
and and he was also able to learn from
his mistakes as you see in the movie
there's a scene in the movie where she
says you just don't understand what is
going on and and it registers with him
and he realizes you know what I might
not understand he has the ability to
listen which makes him maybe an even
better man ooh interesting um you had an
opportunity to meet with Ruth what was
it about her character that stood out to
you the most or what will stay with you
the longest I Shh you know I mean not to
overly romanticized things but when you
walk into her private chambers and she's
there sort of like inform obvious she's
very short but at the same time she's so
powerful and her mind is so sharp yeah I
mean she might be 85 years old but she
still has Total Recall access to all of
her facilities I mean she she seems like
she could go for another 10 15 years no
problem so I mean I was really inspired
fingers crossed right let's hold yeah
tell us about working with Mimi and why
it was essential to have a female
director for this movie
you know Mimi had so much in common
there was a real kindred spirit with
Ruth Bader Ginsburg I mean both of them
are women
in an industry where women do not
statistically thrive as as often as men
do
Mimi has broken a glass ceiling before
as as Ruth has and and Mimi was
incredibly passionate about this and
also you know it working with Mimi
really highlighted something to me where
I was like I've been making movies for
almost 15 years now something like that
and this is the first time I've ever
made a feature film with a woman
director Wow yeah and it's like that's
kind of crazy like I mean it's it's
almost like embarrassing so to tell a
story like this if you'd have just
handed off to a male director I think
that would have just been like a cop out
you know yeah tell us about working in
our beloved city of Montreal our beloved
Canadian City I love much well I've made
a few movies in Montreal that might have
been a part of why I took this movie
like we're shooting in Montreal is like
great let's go
I mean that the food scene the the
culture the the beauty of the city I
mean we we shot Denver New York in New
Jersey we shot all these different
places in Montreal I mean it's just an
incredible place to to make movies